talking of hit movies shawshank
redemption' are obviously mo no great
one of your motion yes puts there you
know best films of all time lists
together it's always on this always on
there and yet that film has never been
changed at the box office and the reason
for that is of course is that the the
only real marketing movies get I think
is word of mouth you can promote it all
you want but if the first few audiences
go there and come back and can't say I
really saw this great film then you're
not gonna go very far though people went
to see the Shawshank Redemption in and
they came back oh man I saw this really
terrific movie it's called the sanction
one day they saw me in the elevator one
time so I saw you in the hudsucker
production
so if you can't get word across then it
just doesn't do well yeah you know you
can't see it anyway Elfie did well the
film that turned you into sort of mr.
narration yeah that was it because it's
so special that that narration and now
we have got a little kind of Shawshank
mashup so would you mind lending your
voice to
I must admit I didn't think much of
Graham Norton first time I laid eyes on
him look like a stiff breeze could blow
him over that was my first impression of
the man I could see why some people took
him for annoying he had a walk and a
talk that just wasn't normal around here
and boy did he drink
he drank like a man without a care or
worry in the world I hope to finish this
talk show one day I hope Michael stops
talking for just me I hope people stop
asking me to do stupid boy so
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]